.
* Nachdenkliche Musik *
In den Ferien wird nur gekocht,
nicht gegessen.
Ich probiere
immer mal wieder etwas aus.
Ich habe kein Kochbuch,
ich koche, wozu ich Lust habe.
Kochen ist in einem gewissen Sinn
auch Entspannung,
wenn man nicht gerade
Unmengen von Sauce anrühren muss.
Es ist auch entspannend,
wenn man für sich alleine ist,
etwas ausprobiert und arbeitet.
* Nachdenkliche Musik *
MIT TELETEXT-UNTERTITELUNG
* Vögel pfeifen. *
Hallo.
- (Papagei) Hallo.
Hallo, Rello. Hallo, Chica.
* Die Vögel und Abt Christian
pfeifen abwechselnd. *
Hallo.
Wieso plusterst du dich auf, Rello?
Was ist los?
Der "Blick" titelte einmal:
"Der Abt hat einen Vogel."
- Ja.
Hat Sie das gestört?
- Überhaupt nicht. Es stimmt ja.
Er hat nicht nur einen,
sondern vier Vögel.
Wir hören sie in voller Pracht.
Vögel sind etwas Lebendiges,
etwas Schönes.
Sie hören gerne Musik.
Das ist hier unmöglich.
Nur mit Kopfhörern
kann ich hier Musik hören.
Dann hören sie die Musik nicht.
Sobald sie die Musik hören,
ist hier eine grosse Diskothek,
weil sie darauf antworten müssen.
Sie signalisieren damit:
"Hier sind wir der Meister."
* Schrille Pfiffe *
- Nun reicht es langsam.
Beruhigt euch mal ein wenig.
* Die Papageien krächzen,
Abt Christian pfeift. *
* Schrilles Pfeifen,
Abt Christian lacht. *
Heiliger Bimbam, wo bist du?
Der wahre Meister
im Kloster Engelberg
ist jedoch Abt Christian Meyer.
Abt bedeutet Vater und bezeichnet
den Vorsteher des Klosters.
* Lautes Krächzen *
Hallo, habt ihr Streit miteinander?
Christian Meyer ist seit zehn Jahren
für die 20 Mönche
und die Klosterbetriebe
verantwortlich.
Mit etwa 100 Angestellten
ist das Kloster nach den Bergbahnen
der zweitgrösste Arbeitgeber
in Engelberg
und feiert ein Jubiläum:
Vor 900 Jahren
wurde das Kloster gegründet.
Vom Klosterdorf
reden die Leute hier oben bis heute -
ohne Kloster kein Dorf.
* Sehnsüchtige Saxofonklänge *
Das kam erst 1926 hinzu -
plus die Vergrösserung hier.
Bis 1926 war es nur dieses Viereck,
die Kirche
und das Viereck an der Kirche.
Das sind alles riesige Klöster.
Ginge es nicht etwas bescheidener?
Natürlich, diese Frage
stellt sich immer wieder.
Gewisse Dinge
könnte man wieder abreissen.
Man hätte wieder mehr Luft
und könnte etwas Neues bauen.
Aber ich denke,
man zieht nicht gerne
von einem Ort weg,
wo 900 Jahre lang
Mönche gelebt haben.
Niemand will in ein kleines Haus
oder eine kleinere Anlage umziehen.
Das eigene Kloster
ist immer das schönste Kloster.
Einige kritisieren, dass Mönche,
die vorgeben, die Armut zu leben,
so grosse Klöster haben.
So ist es.
Aber das ist etwas,
das im Ganzen gewachsen ist.
Wir haben
kein persönliches Bankkonto.
Das ganze Geld fliesst
in die Gemeinschaftskasse.
Vor genau 900 Jahren wurde
das Kloster Engelberg gegründet.
Und jetzt vermiest ein Virus
dem Abt das Jubiläumsjahr.
Wegen der Corona-Pandemie
befindet sich das Kloster
im Frühjahr im Lockdown -
eine Herausforderung
auch für Hauswart Thomas Infanger.
Sind die letzten Reinigungsarbeiten
im Kollegium fällig?
Ja, wir sind bald fertig
mit den Vorbereitungen
für das Kollegium, die Schule
und die Aussenanlagen.
Was ist passiert?
Ich habe die Wand geküsst.
Bei uns im Internat?
Nein, am Wochenende.
Wenn es zu Hause passiert ist,
ist es nicht so schlimm.
Auf dem Campus haben wir
viele verschiedene Institutionen.
Wir haben da die Schule,
eingemietete Schulen ...
Wir müssen die Schutzkonzepte
unter einen Hut bringen.
Dann haben wir ein Internat
mit einem eigenen Schutzkonzept,
das auch für die Mensa gilt.
Zudem haben wir eine Gastabteilung
und verschiedene Betriebe.
Die Schutzkonzepte müssen
sehr individuell gestaltet werden.
Wir haben Seminare, Anlässe ...
Wie können wir diese durchführen?
Es ist ein ständiger Prozess.
Im Kloster treffen die Mönche
einen historischen Entscheid:
Wegen COVID teilen sie
die Gemeinschaft in zwei Gruppen auf.
Die jüngeren Mönche
mit vielen Aussenkontakten
ziehen ins Internat um.
* Liturgischer Gesang *
# Ich will dich erheben,
mein Gott und König ...
# ... und deinen Namen preisen
immer und ewig.
Von den jüngeren Patres
sind heute nur Guido Muff
und Andri Tuor beim Gebet.
Sie leben nun getrennt
von den älteren Mönchen,
die so vor einer möglichen Ansteckung
geschützt werden sollen.
# Ehre sei dem Vater und dem Sohne
und dem Heiligen Geiste.
# Wie im Anfang, so auch jetzt
und alle Zeit und in Ewigkeit.
# Amen.
Pater Guido und Pater Andri hoffen,
bald wieder in die Gemeinschaft
der Mönche zurückzukehren.
Noch aber brauchen sie Geduld.
Trotz Lockdown und Kurzarbeit
in einzelnen Klosterbetrieben
ist der Abt
jedoch nicht in Alarmstimmung.
Aus den vergangenen fünf Jahren
haben wir gewisse Rückstellungen.
Zudem hoffen wir,
dass es in den nächsten Jahren
wieder etwas besser wird.
Der heilige Benedikt
ist der Grund,
wieso ich nicht nervös
irgendwo herumschwirre.
Der heilige Benedikt
schreibt in den Regeln,
der Abt soll sich ums Vermögen
des Klosters keine Sorgen machen.
Wichtig ist, dass es
um die Menschen geht, die Mitbrüder
und das Kloster an und für sich,
als Gebetstätte,
Zeugnisstätte, Lebensstätte,
wo man den Glauben
tagtäglich zu leben versucht.
Darum geht es, nicht um das grosse
oder kleine Vermögen.
So, in Gottes Namen fahren wir.
Der Abt ist auch
der Aussenminister des Klosters
und darum viel unterwegs.
Beim Autofahren
geniesst Christian Meyer die Musik -
wenn schon einmal
keine Papageien krächzen.
* Melodiöse Popmusik
aus dem Autoradio, Summen *
Heute nimmt sich der Abt Zeit
für einen privaten Besuch in Basel -
bei einem seiner beiden Brüder,
bei Robert Meyer.
Die beiden sind unterwegs
auf den Spuren ihrer Kindheit
an der Spitalstrasse gegenüber
dem Universitätsspital Basel.
Unsere Wohnung
war zuoberst in diesem Haus.
Was wohl jetzt dort drin ist?
Sonst ist alles noch gleich,
zumindest äusserlich.
Ich bin gespannt, wie es
innen aussieht.- Ich auch.
Also, gehen wir.
Im ehemaligen Geschäftshaus werden
heute Heroinabhängige behandelt,
in einer Einrichtung
der Universitären
Psychiatrischen Kliniken Basel.
Grüezi.
Das war die Petition.
Mutter kochte hier jeweils Kaffee,
Filterkaffee für die Angestellten.
Damals gab es noch keine Automaten.
Die Mitarbeiterin Selina Winter
führt die beiden Brüder
in die ehemalige Wohnung.
Der Vater war Hauswart.
Der Abt und seine beiden Brüder
wuchsen
in einfachen Verhältnissen auf.
Dort war das Elternschlafzimmer,
hier mein Zimmer.
Erinnerst du dich noch an diese Tür?
Das ist ja noch dieselbe Tür!
Das war die Küchentür.
Wir dürfen nicht erzählen,
was mit ihr alles passiert ist.
Es ist immer noch dieselbe Tür.
Wir spielten immer
Fussball im Wohnzimmer.
Ist das von Ihnen?
- Ab und zu fiel die Füllung raus.
Mit dem Fleischklopfer
versuchten wir jeweils,
den Schaden zu reparieren.
Hier waren die beiden Türen.
Dort war der Flur.
Beim Fussballspielen
sind wir nicht rumgerannt.
Ziel war es,
die Kugel in die gegnerische Tür,
ins gegnerische Tor zu schiessen.
Und manchmal landete die Kugel ...
* Räuspern *
Das war alles einmal leer.
Wir mussten alles wieder flicken.
Sonst hätten wir Ärger
mit Vater bekommen.
Er hat es nie gemerkt.
Herr Meyer, haben Sie auch
ein so religiöses Gen wie der Abt?
Das ist jetzt eine Fangfrage.
Nein, irgendwie, das ist ...
Ich weiss nicht, woher er ...
Doch, Mutter hat ihn geprägt.
Er hat dieses Gen von ihr geerbt.
Ich und der ältere Bruder
waren eher von Vater geprägt.
Wir landeten deshalb eher
auf der sportlichen Seite.
Er wusste schon sehr früh,
dass er Pfarrer werden will.
Das konnten wir nicht nachvollziehen
in unseren jungen Jahren.
Aber er ist zielstrebig
seinen Weg gegangen.
Und er ist eigentlich schon ...
Ich finde das heute eindrücklich.
In der ersten oder zweiten Oberstufe
sagte er, er wolle Pfarrer werden.
Aber er war in der Realschule,
der heutigen Sekundarschule.
Er hätte dafür aber
die Matura benötigt.
Und dann ist das ...
- Mit dem Pfarrer ...
Mit Pfarrer Füglister
wurde dann eine Art Deal vereinbart.
Woran lag es, dass ich
nicht das Gymnasium besuchte?
Wir sind eher praktische Menschen.
Wir arbeiten gerne mit den Händen,
wir waren nie kopflastige Menschen.
Das ist bis heute so.
Ich bin eher der Praktiker.
Deshalb brauchte ich
ein wenig Druck.
So kam ich dann
ins Internat nach Engelberg.
Die Beaufsichtigung und Betreuung
halfen mir,
das Gymnasium
erfolgreich zu absolvieren.
Was für eine Religiosität
lebte Ihre Mutter?
Meine Mutter und meine Grossmutter
waren streng katholisch.
Sie waren halt badisch geprägt.
Meine Grossmutter erlebte
beide Weltkriege hautnah mit.
Meine Mutter
war das älteste von sechs Kindern.
Sie erlebte den Zweiten Weltkrieg
natürlich auch hautnah mit.
Meine Mutter hätte perfekt in ein
Kloster gepasst, als Klosterfrau.
Aber dann lernten sie sich kennen,
unser Vater und unsere Mutter.
Hier sieht man
die geballte Direktion.
Ja, das ist Vater.
Der Vater ist reformiert,
die Mutter römisch-katholisch -
in den 1950er-Jahren
keine selbstverständliche Ehe.
Die Eltern sind inzwischen gestorben.
Auf diesem Bild sind wir zu dritt.
Ich nehme an,
das war in der Lange Erlen.
Noch schwarz-weiss,
ohne Datum auf der Rückseite.
Bei den Ziegen.
Die Tierliebe
begann bei Ihnen schon früh.
Ja, wir hatten auch Wellensittiche.
Wir hatten einen Zwerghasen.
Eine Katze, die 21 Jahre alt wurde.
Und dann war da
diese berühmte Story:
du im Kloster, im Internat
mit dieser 6 m langen Schlange ...
Im Kollegium hatte es
einen Zoo mit einer Würgeschlage,
die ich betreute.
Diese nahm er einmal mit
zum Tierarzt im Zoo Basel,
weil sonst niemand helfen konnte.
Sie hatte eine Lungenentzündung.
Sie brauchte Kamillenbäder.
- Und Injektionen.
Als ich morgens ins Bad ging und
mich rasieren und waschen wollte,
lag die Schlange in der Badewanne.
Ich hätte fast
eine Herzattacke erlitten.
Du hast manchmal
schon seltsame Dinge getan.
Das passt doch
zu uns als Familie Meyer.
Wir sind so ...
- Das war wirklich ...
Und wir hatten keine Angst.
- Ja.
* Nachdenkliche, perlende Musik *
* Sehnsüchtige Saxofonklänge *
Das ist das Maturafoto
unserer Klasse.
Pater Guido und ich
waren in derselben Klasse,
die 1987 die Matura ablegte.
Und hier ist das Klassenfoto
aus dieser Zeit.
Damals waren wir noch jung,
jung und schlank.
Hier ist Pater Guido.
Und ich bin ...
Jetzt muss ich mich selber suchen.
... hier.
Ein Kloster,
keine Frauen, kein Besitz -
es wirkt lustfeindlich.
Warum gingen Sie ins Kloster?
Können Sie das noch erklären?
Oje.
Erst einmal:
Es ist nicht lustfeindlich.
Wir Benediktiner sind Geniesser -
ich denke,
das haben Sie auch wahrgenommen.
Die Liturgie ist uns wichtig -
und das gemeinsame Essen.
Da sind wir wirklich auch Geniesser.
Und lustlos sind wir sicher nicht.
Ich ging ins Kloster,
weil ich die Vorstellung hatte,
mich auf Jesus Christus ...
Den Anstoss gab auch "Die Sache Jesu
braucht Begeisterte",
ein damals neues Lied,
ungefähr aus den 70er-Jahren.
"Die Sache Jesu
braucht Begeisterte" ...
In einem Kloster, denke ich,
in einer Gemeinschaft,
kann man von dieser Begeisterung
noch etwas mehr Zeugnis geben
denn als Einzelkämpfer.
Mit Einzelkämpfern meint Christian
Meyer die Priester in den Pfarreien.
Er selber war 14 Jahre lang
Pfarrer von Engelberg.
Das Kloster ist nämlich auch
für die Pfarrei im Dorf zuständig
und einer der Mönche der Pfarrer.
Ich liebe sie immer noch.
Ich schaue manchmal
wehmütig darauf zurück.
Es war für mich
eine sehr lebendige, spannende Zeit.
Ich arbeitete
mit jungen Eltern zusammen,
stellte eine Familien-Maiandacht
auf die Beine.
So versuchte ich,
die Menschen etwas mehr
an die Gemeinschaft der Kirche,
letztlich an die Gemeinschaft
von uns allen, zu binden.
Seelsorger ist er geblieben,
auch als Abt.
Das zahlt sich jetzt
in Corona-Zeiten aus.
Christian Meyer unterstützt seine
Mitbrüder und fördert ihre Talente.
Das Kloster hat immer wieder
Komponisten, Organisten
oder bildende Künstler hervor-
gebracht, so wie Pater Eugen Bollin.
Guten Morgen.
Fleissig bei der Arbeit?
Du bist sehr früh dran.
- Ja, ja.
Arbeitest du wieder
an einer neuen Collage?
Ja, Collage Engel.
Engel?
- Engel und Tanzende.
Mit einem Ausschnitt
aus unserem Deckengewölbe.
Jawohl, ich zitiere die Engel
aus unserer eigenen Kirche ständig.
Gut.
Woher hast du diese Bilder?
Hast du sie irgendwo ausgeschnitten
oder mit dem Handy fotografiert?
Nein, nein.
Ich habe sie aus dem Fotobuch
unserer Kirche ausgeschnitten.
Und hier hinten geht es so weiter.
In die hinterste Stube:
Kopf einziehen, es wird eng.
Ich habe lange mit einer Balletteuse
und ihrer Tochter
zusammengearbeitet.
Und aus diesem Spiel hat sich später
der Engel entwickelt.
Es ist unglaublich,
wie du mit dem Stift umgehen kannst,
und wie einfach etwas entsteht.
Das ist unglaublich.
Ich habe diese Figuren
natürlich so viele Male gezeichnet,
sodass ich sie im Kopf habe
und sie in jeder Situation
und Stellung einsetzen kann.
Das ist der Vorteil.
Es braucht sehr viel Vorarbeit,
damit man frei zeichnen kann.
Damit man frei kombinieren kann.
Der Engel als Motiv ist sehr alt,
im Barock wird es oft verwendet.
Abt Christian, der eine ist be-
gnadeter Maler, der andere Sportler.
Wo ist die Grenze?
Ach, die Grenze.
Es muss einfach
irgendwie normal bleiben.
Uns war eigentlich klar,
was z.B. die Sportler betrifft,
dass das Rucksackfliegen,
das Paragliding nicht erlaubt wird,
weil wir jeden im Kloster brauchen.
Wenn ein Unfall passieren würde ...
Wobei ihn
selbst beim Spazieren hier draussen
ein fallender Dachziegel
am Kopf treffen könnte.
Dann wäre auch Schluss.
Man muss das
im Verhältnis betrachten.
Die Berufung und das klösterliche
Leben dürfen nicht darunter leiden.
Das gibt die Grenzen vor.
Die Mausfalle ist zu
und der Käse verrottet.
Ihre Arbeit unterbrechen die Mönche
fünfmal am Tag
und beten und singen
alte Texte aus der Bibel.
Die Gemeinschaft in Engelberg
zählt derzeit 20 Mönche.
Durchschnittsalter: 63 Jahre.
* Glocke, liturgischer Gesang *
# Gloria Patri
et Filio et Spiritui Sancto.
# Ehre sei dem Vater
und dem Sohne.
# Und dem Heiligen Geiste.
# Wie im Anfang,
so auch jetzt und alle Zeit.
# Und in Ewigkeit, Amen.
Wegen Corona zählen die meisten
Mönche zur Hochrisikogruppe.
Für diesen Film konnten wir
wegen Vorsichtsmassnahmen
lediglich dieses Gebet,
aber keine Mahlzeiten oder
Zusammenkünfte der Mönche filmen.
# Den Trotz der Frevler
werde ich brechen,
doch das Haupt des Gerechten
wird erhoben.
# Ehre sei dem Vater und dem Sohne.
Die Zukunft des Klosters ist wegen
der Überalterung der Mönche ungewiss.
An den Versprechen aber
wird nicht gerüttelt,
darunter Armut,
Gehorsam und Ehelosigkeit.
Haben Sie daran gedacht,
mit diesem Mann oder mit jener Frau
eine Familie zu gründen?
Haben Sie sich nie gefragt: "Ich bin
hier auf dem falschen Dampfer?"
Jein.
Eine Freundin und ich
beschlossen einst, zu heiraten.
Dann musste ich ihr sagen:
"Es wird doch nichts."
Erst wollte sie auch nicht heiraten,
hat dann doch geheiratet
und drei Kinder grossgezogen.
Wir pflegen unsere Beziehung
noch immer.
Zu Beginn wurmte es mich
am stärksten bei Taufzeremonien,
weil für mich das Familienleben
eigentlich etwas Wichtiges ist.
Wenn bei Taufzeremonien die Eltern
im gleichen Alter wie ich waren,
und ich beim Anblick des Taufkindes
dachte,
es könnte auch mein Kind sein ...
In solchen Momenten begann es,
in meinem Kopf wieder zu drehen.
Andererseits hätte ich mich dann
niemals als Pfarrer
so einsetzen können,
hätte meinen Weg niemals so
gestalten können, wie ich es tat.
Viele Menschen fragen sich:
"Wie gehen Sie als Mönch
mit der Sexualität um?"
"Wir nehmen Ihnen das
mit dem Zölibat nicht ab."
Da frage ich Sie: "Wie halten Sie es
mit der Sexualität?"
Es ist nie einfach.
Ob verheiratet oder ledig,
Sexualität ist eine Kraft,
eine Macht in uns.
Und dieser Macht und Kraft
muss sich jeder selbst stellen.
Verheiratet zu sein, bedeutet nicht,
dass es klappt.
Ledig zu sein, bedeutet nicht,
Da lernen wir Menschen ständig,
auch ich.
Manchmal zerreisst es mich ...
Man steckt es nicht einfach weg
wie ein Paar Schuhe,
die man vor die Haustür stellt,
und dann ist es erledigt,
sondern das ist ein Teil,
der mich auch auszeichnet.
Die Sexualität gehört zu meinem Ich.
Es ist nicht einfach
etwas Negatives.
Aber jeder und jede von uns
muss lernen, damit zu leben,
auch in einer
Gemeinschaftsbeziehung.
Oh, sie spielen.
Seit seiner Zeit als Pfarrer
begleitet Christian Meyer
die Pfadi Engelberg,
im Sommer jeweils im Lager
der Wölfli, der kleinen Pfadfinder.
Das ist ein ungewohntes Bild.
Der Abt von Engelberg steht mit
einer Frau in der Küche und kocht,
ein eingespieltes Team.
- Das sind wir.
Seit 14 Jahren machen wir das
und wissen langsam, wie es geht.
Wenn die eine dies macht,
tut der andere jenes.
Das läuft einfach ineinander.
* Brutzeln *
Geht das?
Pass auf, das ist heiss!
Von aussen betrachtet
sieht es aus wie ein altes Ehepaar.
Genau das haben wir vorher gesagt,
als wir zusammen auf der Bank sassen
und auf Sie gewartet haben.
Oben im Gemeinschaftsraum
hängt das "Man munkelt"-Plakat
Zum ersten Mal seit 14 Jahren
schrieben die Kinder:
"Medix und Ratatouille gleich Herz."
Das erste Mal.
Wir meinten noch,
es habe lange gedauert.
Wie erklären Sie das
den Mönchen im Kloster?
Da gibt es gar nichts zu erklären,
weil sie nichts davon wissen.
Hanny Niederberger heisst in der
Pfadi Ratatouille, der Abt Medix.
Kochen ist sein Hobby.
Nur hat der Abt im Kloster
keine Gelegenheit, zu kochen.
Darum geniesst er die Arbeit in
der Küche im Wölfli-Lager umso mehr.
Mit Medix bezeichnet man übrigens
jemanden, der mehr tut, als er muss.
Noch ein Poulet?
Welches? Dieses hier?
Kocht der Abt gut?
- Ja.
Haben sie etwas besonders Leckeres
gekocht diese Woche?
Das ist das Leckerste.
Das ist mein Lieblingsessen.
Sie sind mit Leib und Seele dabei.
Ich habe einfach Freude.
Freude gehört dazu.
Sonst könnten wir
nicht etwas Positives
den Kinder und Jugendlichen
weitergeben,
mit denen wir hier zusammenleben
und eine Woche bis 14 Tage
unterwegs sind.
Darum braucht es dazu Herzblut.
Es gab kein Tischgebet.
- Nein.
Wir sind hier eine gemischte Gruppe.
Und nur weil der Abt dabei ist,
muss man nicht frömmer tun
als zu Hause.
Ich denke, das ist auch wichtig.
* Sanft anschwellender Flötenklang *
Es ist ein heikles Thema
und die grösste Krise
der römisch-katholischen Kirche
in ihrer jüngeren Geschichte:
die sexuellen Übergriffe
von Priestern und Ordensleuten
auf Frauen und Kinder.
Christian Meyer schaut selbstkritisch
auf seine Kirche:
Wo so etwas
in einer moralischen Institution
wie der katholischen Kirche
passiert,
entdeckt man plötzlich,
dass es ein ausgehöhltes System ist,
das von Macht
und Klerikalismus getrieben
der Problembewältigung
ausgewichen ist.
Man hat die Täter versetzt,
war aber letztlich nie konsequent.
Mit der Moralvorstellung, die man
den Leuten vor Augen gehalten hat,
ist man intern
nicht konsequent umgegangen.
Wir hatten Fälle von Missbrauch.
Ein gravierender Fall
war in den 60er-Jahren.
Dieser Fall
wurde staatsrechtlich angegangen
und es fand auch
eine Gerichtsverhandlung statt,
die mit einer Verurteilung endete.
Der Mitbruder musste ins Gefängnis,
hat die Gefängnisstrafe abgesessen.
Als er zurückgekehrt ist,
hat man ihn an einem Ort eingesetzt,
wo er nicht mit Jugendlichen
in Berührung kommt.
Just in der Zeit, als das Thema
Missbrauch immer drängender wurde,
wurde ich zum Abt gewählt.
Wir riefen in unserer Hauszeitung
"Titlisgrüsse" mehrmals dazu auf,
dass sich ehemalige Schüler
melden sollten,
die etwas darüber wissen
oder so was selbst erlebt haben.
Diesen Fällen fing man nach.
Man suchte im Archiv nach Spuren,
nach Hinweisen auf Missbrauch usw.
Die Ergebnisse wurden dann
den Mitbrüdern und dem Kloster
als Rechenschaftsbericht vorgelegt.
Nach der Sommerpause ist der Abt
erneut wegen Corona gefordert:
Schutzkonzepte müssen in Kirche
und Kloster umgesetzt werden.
* Nachdenkliche Musik *
Sie haben monatelang
ausserhalb der Gemeinschaft gelebt,
nun sind Pater Andri und Pater Guido
zurück und erleichtert.
Pater Andri
hat inzwischen Karriere gemacht:
Er ist vom Abt zum Rektor
des Gymnasiums ernannt worden.
Als Rektor wirst du auch spüren,
dass nicht immer alle
auf derselben Seite stehen.
Schon auf derselben Seite -
aber mit einem sanften Gegendruck.
Ermutigen, bestärken, fördern:
Christian Meyer ist ein offener Abt
und auch ein Seelsorger
für die Mönche.
Ich gebe das Zeichen für die Kamera.
Ihr könnte loslegen, wann ihr wollt.
Beat, du achtest darauf,
falls sie Unsinn erzählen.
900 Jahre Kloster Engelberg -
das Jubiläumsfest ist verschoben.
Dafür gibt es ein Gespräch
mit dem Talammann von Engelberg,
Alex Höchli, fürs Internet
über die Bedeutung des Klosters.
Ein Klosterdorf bedeutet nicht,
dass die Dorfbewohner
sehr fromm sind
und jeden Sonntag
in die Kirche gehen.
Es ist ein Hinweis
auf den Ursprung des Dorfs.
Das Klosterdorf lebt - bis heute.
Ich glaube, der Zusatz Kloster
gehört zu Engelberg.
Nur Dorf, Engelberg Dorf,
das klingt sehr schlicht.
Hallo zusammen.
- Guten Tag.
Zivilisten gegen Trachten.
* Lachen *
Die höchste Prominenz von Engelberg.
Bis zu seiner Wahl zum Abt
sang Christian Meyer
im Jodlerklub Engelberg.
Bei der Jodlergruppe Titlis
singt er jetzt spontan mit -
ein Abt mit Leib und Seele.
# Oh Engelberg, du herrliches Dorf.
# Nichts lässt sich mit dir messen.
# Es plagt einen das Heimweh überall.
# Man kann dich nicht vergessen.
* Jodeln *
SWISS TXT AG / Access Services
Ph. Schlatter, R. Schmid - 2020